and tonight Station Casinos with a whole
bunch of Fireworks shows with the help
of fireworks by Gucci our Mary Jane
valiazza is out at the Red Rock Casino
on the west side of town of Charleston
in the 215. how's it going out there
Mary Jane
well Nate happy Fourth of July to you
and Station Casinos will host its annual
firework spectacular display at all six
of its properties including right here
at Red Rock Casino and Hotel in
Summerlin Joe yalda the vice president
of guest experience says preparation
takes months of planning and Station
Casinos will have a synchronized
fireworks playlist with their show
running over 20 minutes both Red Rock
and Green Valley Ranch will host a
firework viewing party from each of the
Resort's main pool starting at 7 30
while Boulder Station Palace and Santa
Fe Station will offer a fireworks
viewing area in their parking lots for
free
best thing about stationary casinos is
our team and they put together these
awesome ideas that are always Community
forward right that's our big thing we
believe in the guest experience and we
believe in Las Vegas so to put this on
for the whole city is something that's
very special to us and something we are
very proud to do for the community
if you're not able to watch the show it
will be live streamed on the station
casino's social media page tickets for
this event does vary it starts at ten
dollars for guests 2 to 11 and 25 for
guests 12 and older in Station Casinos
will shoot off their fireworks at the
top of the parking garages it does start
at 9 00 pm tonight and they do say does
get busy it does get packed so the
earlier you can come down here the
better reporting live from Red Rock
Station Casinos and hotel Mary June live
local now